Hilary Clinton she was interviewed by
those fun people over at Fox News who
Fox News scary right she sat in between
Greta Van Susteren on one side Brett
Baier on the other she got pretty severe
whiplash from the questioning of course
literally half of it was about Benghazi
have you heard there's some kind of
situation the Republicans are all going
crazy about let's take a look
my own assessment careened from you know
the video had something to do with that
the video had nothing to do with it it
may have affected some people it didn't
affect other people and I think the the
conclusion to draw because we were not
just monitoring what was happening in
Benghazi once it began to unfold but
remember we had a very dangerous assault
on our embassy in Cairo that same day
which was clearly linked to that video
so I was trying to make sense of it and
you know I think that the investigations
that have been carried out basically
conclude we can't say that everybody was
influenced and we can't say everybody
wasn't but what the intelligence
community said was spontaneous protests
and that is what at the time they
thought okay so actually if she did what
a lot of politicians who she didn't
really say anything we sort of knew we
kind of didn't know we did the best we
could but I actually pretty much think
that's the truth I don't think they
intentionally tried to get these people
killed I tend to think they probably did
the best they could to secure our
embassy and our people there so without
getting into the nitty-gritty of
Benghazi which no one seems to know the
truth about when they do questions like
this on Fox News
what's the goal is the goal to just keep
hitting the base is the goal to change
any did like does she think she's
changing anyone's mind with an answer
like that does Fox think they're
changing I just wanted like the bigger
sort of media question about it well
first can I just say the girl looks good
and royal blue great choice for her
that's her way of saying I'm a real
Democrat Hillary jewel tones red by the
way thank you I think I think that's a
fair question because when you're
invited onto a show present company
excluded I think the point is to either
you know paint you into a corner make
you look stupid or get you to say
something completely outrageous that
you'd never want to say and I think her
whole job which I think she did a great
job that was just
taking the fuel out of the fire quelling
if she did a little double-talk and was
super vague I think she did what she was
supposed to do right so is that their
purpose they bring her on there they
know she's not gonna say anything and
that's pretty much what she did we sort
of knew we didn't know about a lot but
it's a fair question and they're going
to ask it and they they want to kind of
poke the bear a little bit and they want
a reaction I think they honestly do want
something that they can you know put on
a headline and say oh look at Hillary
she did this and they might even try to
spend something that she did say but
like you said she played it safe and it
was vague but I think a lot of times in
politics you have to keep it vague
because when you say something and you
kind of have to go back on that oh my
god the walls come crashing down on you
imagine having to tell the truth and
saying what you actually believe people
would people would freak out this isn't
just some random woman I mean this is
somebody who's going to be running for
president presumably this is somebody
who's been obviously super connected to
the Obama White House because she works
for him
so what do they expect her to say right
so so that's the thing do you think this
is more about them attacking Obama or
attacking her is this their preemption
on 2016 like we got to keep this thing
going
we know Obama is out no matter what so
forget him let's just keep the pressure
on her why not double down I mean if
they it doesn't matter
it's either if they're trying to get get
Obama presently or get her for the
future they win either way
yeah all right I mean it's Fox News I
don't think anyone surprised it's kind
of like their mo that's what they do
so speaking of their mo so let's get
away from Benghazi I think that's the
interesting thing here is that everyone
was framing this as Hillary's going a
Fox News it's so scary but in a weird
way isn't that a condemnation in that's
no defense of Fox News but isn't that a
condemnation of the rest of our media
because the implication is well the rest
of the media loves her they give her
softball questions all the time but now
she's going on Fox News and it's really
scary and actually if you watch the
interview i watch the whole thing wasn't
that scary there was nothing
particularly you know pointed yeah it
was pretty tame so isn't it a bigger
condemnation of the media that we saw
that we have one outlet that's supposed
to be the scary one for Democrats I
think just historically they have been
the [ __ ] of TV I mean that's what
they know they kind of set themselves up
that
so that now we are just so accustomed to
saying old fox news fox news but like
you said we watch it it's pretty tame
but we're still gonna be like oh here
she's going to fox news it's just the
history of what they've done
yeah they dug that hole for themselves
so it's not like the world pouncing on
them for no reason right if you want to
be sensational it's be sensationalist
but don't be mad when people assume
that's what you're gonna do again and I
will say I don't think the rest of the
media gives our softball questions I
think they they ask the pertinent
questions but they're not coming from a
vicious malicious angle and I think in
the past maybe not with this interview
but in past that's what Fox News does
yeah so we've done a bunch of stories on
her and I absolutely can't support her I
just don't think we need political
dynasties her husband was president I
think no one in my family has been
president I think if you someone in your
family has been president sorry you
don't get to be president win concert
tickets if you're so so I'm just
completely against her because I just I
just think we need fresh new people this
is just gonna be more of the same you
George Bush had his son do it like I
just don't think orient people are
saying that Michelle Obama might run for
Senate in in Illinois
like it's just endless it's endless but
so my so my final question is as women
because you are women so you must
represent all women that's all women do
you are you more inclined to vote for
her I'm gonna be honest yes yeah and I I
didn't vote for Obama just because he
was black but hey I'm not gonna lie that
was a part of it it's like you want that
as the african-american want me you want
that as a woman I want to see her in the
White House and I know what we say about
you know the same old rigmarole but you
also want someone you can trust and so
because she's been in it and because I
love Clinton as a president I'm more
inclined to say okay she's a woman she
understands that and she knows the game
she knows these people and so I just
trust her a little bit more I don't want
some guy I've never heard of before
coming in like oh I'll save the day I
just
that's what I hear yeah and in a weird
way I would be more inclined to vote for
Bill again so I guess that takes a
little bit away from what I said before
but what do you think does that would it
push you a little bit
honestly I I don't know why like if I'm
saying this because I'm exhausted and
got four hours of sleep because of a cat
situation that I was dealing with or
because I really believe I don't know
but at this moment I really feel like
that stuff can't matter it can't matter
if she's a woman it can't matter it it
just can't yeah so I I'm not I don't
want to just completely count her out
like this girl because she would be part
of this dynasty and I can't say well it
doesn't matter what she stands for I
want to support her because she's women
I just I maybe there's a part of me that
does feel that way I don't know I don't
think so though I just I can't have
those be the reasons yeah for me